Hello and welcome to this next video. In this we're going to have a look at some of the more
advanced ways of creating tasks in order to do stuff within the Behaviour Tree.
Right, so we're back into the engine now and let's create another task.
This time what we're going to do is we're going to use our interface slightly.
So the first thing I'm going to do is I'll do one from up here again.
So under this I'm going to create a new task. I'm going to use the bt-task-blueprint-base
and I'm going to call this bt underscore change comma.
Okay and save. So again we're back here and for this what I'm going to do is go override
I'm just going to use receive execute. Now I want to be able to change the color.
I'm going to use this node in a number of different places and I'm going to change to
different colors. Therefore what I want to have is a variable which will allow me to determine
which color this task is going to use. So I just add to a variable and I'm going to call this
color. I'm going to make it instance editable and on the boolean I'm going to be looking for
linear color. Now there are a couple other colors in here but make sure you're using
linear color. Okay now if I drag off of the actor and I type in change color
and I'm going to use a message. I'm going to drag in our color and plug it in there.
Now I want to do one final thing and that is the finish execute and because I'm using a message
it's not so simple to figure out if this is a success or a failure. So I'm just gonna click
the default as a success. So again all this does is it will receive execute and it will send
a message via an interface to the actor telling it to change color and then it's going to finish
the execute. Now let's have a quick look at the interface because we should have gone over
interfaces by now but what they do is they maintain a means to communicate between different
actors. You see I have BI MPC if I open this up you can see down the right hand side I have
a number of different functions. What an interface does is it just defines a method
of communicating between the blueprints and then if what you're sending the message to has
that interface applied to it it will do something on that. Now this is quite nice for a task
because it means that any of the code that we write isn't class dependent. So this doesn't
actually know or care what class your MPC is. It's going to send the task, it's going to send
the message regardless. It may not even have this to implement then it would do nothing.
However if we have a quick look at our MPC character you can see that I've already written
some code here and it's event change color and we have the interface implemented there
and if we double click on that it's just changing the tint on a material that the
character has. So you can see this on construction script. Don't worry too much about that just bear
in mind that it's sending the instruction to change color and then it's finishing the execute.
I'm going to compile and save. Next up we're going to create one more task and this time
I'll do it in a different way. I'm going to right hand click come up to blueprint task
and under classes I am going to search for task and we should see here that we have a
bt task blueprint base and so this is just the other way that I can create
a blueprint. I'm going to call this bt underscore change speed. Double click on that
and on the override again I'm just going to look for receive execute and I will need a
variable determining the speed as the input so I will change or create a speed variable
make it a float and make it instance editable and I'm going to use the interface again to drag
off and go change speed message I'll drag in the speed that and again at the end I'm going
to do p finish execute I'll mark this as a success so again I'm using the interface
and the code is all on the pawn but because we're using an interface they aren't dependent
on each other so you could write a completely different method of changing the color of or by
changing the speed and still use exactly the same task in a different in a different behavior tree
let's save and compile and now I'm going to jump back into the baby tree and I'm going to
do a little bit more from this so for the wonder about the first thing that I want to do
is change the speed change the speed and I am going to set this to 200 because we're wondering
about we don't really want them running around the place and then I'm going to drag off and
I'm going to do change color and again we have a color up here I'm going to change this to yellow
so that is full one on red one on green and blue zero so again these are the ones that I
marked as instance editable and now we have two functions so if we were to look at this
what it does it starts off by changing the speed to 200 then changes the color to yellow finds a
random location moves to it and then waits for one second then it will go all the way back to
the top and it will repeat the process let's save and let's kick that off so now you can see this
is working our characters are yellow and they are wandering around accordingly so they're just
moving around slowly to a location now escape there so that's adding in our extra to our two
elements and what I'd like to do at this point is have a look at how we can visualize what the
um the baby tree is actually doing so if I was to hit play again but I'm not going to jump
into the character game here I'm actually going to jump to our baby tree now what we see with
the baby tree we can actually watch this in action you see at the moment it's going to move to
and then it will wait for one second you can see here we have a drop down and this is going to
give us access to all of the other different pi controllers so I can select any of them they're
all pretty much doing the same thing but it will allow me to watch them as as the game
is running and this is really useful because if you want to figure out why something's getting
stuck or what it's doing you're able to watch them as it's running you can also see that down
here we have the content of the blackboard so we've not set the player but we have set the location
and the self-actor so that's just a useful method of seeing what the behavior tree is doing
at any one time I'm going to come back into here and just stop it and I think we will stop
there for this video in the next video we're going to look at creating a completely different
set of actions and show how we would make the decision to
change over to a different side of the behavior tree